the people may have spoken but by no
means are all the people in divided
Brazil listening
truckers are blocking highways in
response to Lula de Silva's razor thin
victory in the presidential election
this is the main road between Sao Paulo
and Rio de Janeiro
these are Jeb bolzanaro supporters who
fear the economic and environmental
changes that the Lula presidency
guarantees and they aren't happy
foreign
the exploitation of the Amazon
rainforest was a key strategy of
President bolsonaro and it resonated
with truckers loggers and farmers
deforestation under bolsonaro increased
every year to record levels Farmers got
rich the indigenous forest dwellers lost
their lands and Lula says all that is
going to stop
environmentalists say the changes must
be quick he has committed to that
recently and yesterday at the police
Avenue
so um
this is actually the argument we have to
say we have no time left it has to be
done now
[Applause]
the election win for Lula signaled the
start of an enormous Street party as
world leaders sent a swathe of
congratulatory messages and phone calls
but the new leader has a lot to do Lula
has an awful lot of issues on his plate
that he has to address straight away one
is obviously the Amazon will will get a
huge amount of international support
he's promising to change all of
bolsonaro's policies on the Amazon and
save the forest which we'll get as I say
huge support abroad and by a lot of
people here the other one though he has
to address is poverty it is a real big
problem here he's promising huge amount
of spending on social housing and
education it's a huge huge job though
poverty and Brazil's social division to
obvious the homeless inhabit the
sidewalks of police that Avenue in Sao
Paulo it's one of the richest streets in
the country
100 million Brazilians live in poverty
Lula is pledging to turn this round
it'll be hard and expensive
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Sao Paulo